[Musique]
bonjour à tous émission spéciale gérard
larcher face à la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour gérard larcher bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
vous êtes le président du sénat nous
sommes 500 pendant une heure et nous
aborderons les différents sujets
d'actualité
cette rentrée et cris inquiète aussi
bien sur le plan sanitaire que sur le
plan économique et social
le plan de relance est il le bon remède
questions de sécurité aussi c'est une
préoccupation pour les français c'est un
sujet dont 100 par le gouvernement
les territoires jean castex n'a que ce
mot à la bouche bonne ou mauvaise
nouvelle pour la droite
nous parlerons du sénat à dix jours de
l'élection sénatoriale et des
républicains quelle ligne quel avenir
pour vous interroger à mes côtés
plusieurs journalistes de la presse
quotidienne régionale dans leurs
rédactions locales baptiste bise à
poitiers pour la nouvelle république
yves-marie robin de ouest france qui est
à rennes eric berger de la dépêche du
midi à toulouse et sébastien cours
atteint à chartres pour l'écho
républicain journal que vous connaissez
bien gérard larcher et sur ce plateau à
mes côtés julien lécuyer de la voix du
nord bonjour julien bonjour et pascal
jalabert du groupe ebra bonjour matinale
et le groupe ebra qui représente les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
on commente gérard larcher donc avec
cette crise sanitaire et ces chiffres du
pauvre qui sont à la hausse encore plus
de 6500 cas recensés hier
est ce que ça vous inquiète est ce que
pour vous la france est prête à faire
face à une deuxième vague
d'abord je suis content d'être avec la
presse quotidienne régionale parce que
je pense que sur les territoires
elle joue un rôle à la fois de la
formation de débat mais aussi de
cohésion
sébastien contact ne sera pas étonné
parce que je pense que cette presse joue
un rôle de cohésion dans un moment où
nous avons besoin de retrouver la
cohésion alors la situation sanitaire
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
et les autorités locales mme paraissent
appropriée et proportionnée
c'est vrai qu'on assiste à une forme de
reprise de l'épidémie encore faut-il
regarder tout ça puisque on a
comparaison du nombre de tests avant
aujourd'hui rend les comparaisons
difficiles faut à tout prix éviter un
confinement généralisée et il faut qu'en
même temps l'économie l'école puisse
fonctionner et permet de dire il faut
pas opposer les générations dans le
débat on a vu un moment on confine pour
protéger je fais ça ap les aînés
maintenant ce serait les jeunes qui
seraient encore je crois que c'est
l'occasion d'une solidarité
intergénérationnelle importante
en tous les cas il faut respecter
naturellement les gestes barrière
s'étend toujours facilement fait ce
qu'il faut pour éviter en tout cas pour
que la france soit prête
je vous ai dit les mesures prises par le
gouvernement et les autorités locales
j'insiste beaucoup sur cet aspect des
choses parce que on a vu dans la crise
souvenez-vous avril mais s'il y en avait
pas eu des maires des conseils
départementaux des conseils régionaux et
je pense que c'est ensemble c'est là où
on voit qu'elle est symbolisée par le
couple préfet baer c'est cette réponse
locale vous pensez vous pensez
réellement que les la la mesure a été
prise au niveau des départements
justement ce couple préfet maire il
fonctionne bien à l'heure actuelle vous
avez des bons ressenti du terrain en
tous les cas il fonctionne beaucoup
mieux parce que l'exécutif me semble
avoir pris une bonne orientation s'est à
nouveau
tu allais dire de confier au préfet au
préfet de département
quand la dimension régionale au préfet
de région j'allais dire une vraie
autorité et il faudra d'ailleurs et ça
nous conduira sur une nouvelle
génération de décentralisation qu'à côté
la décentralisation n'est une
déconcentration et qu'on est à préfet
qui est des vrais pouvoirs des vraies
responsabilités y compris sur les
agences régionales
vous vous êtes vous fait tester bien sûr
je d'abord parce que j'ai une suspicion
et en rentrant d'un déplacement en
afrique à la fin du mois de février
début mars
et je me fais tester extrêmement
régulièrement c'est-à-dire tous les
persos de la semaine toutes les
personnalités publiques qui se déplace
beaucoup doivent août elle se fait un
test est fini des c'est la décision de
chacun si j'ai d'ailleurs sur la
question des tests
une observation je le disais au premier
ministre dans la conférence téléphonique
que nous avions eue mardi la semaine
dernière et là il faut définir des
priorités
ça fonctionne encore pas bien dans ma
propre ville rambouillet il a fallu des
initiatives autour de l'hôpital
des médecins libéraux des infirmières
libérales pour qu'on établisse une
priorité ceux qui présentent une
suspicion travers de symptômes
ceux qui ont un ressenti ou une
inquiétude ceux qui ont croisé ou
partager avec des personnes qui sont
révélés positifs
il ya là des priorités les tests pour
tout le monde prioriser ceux qui doivent
arrêter mais prioriser comme joris et ça
veut pas dire arrêter comment vous
observez vous qui êtes un scientifique
de formation cette émergence d'aider nos
masques nos vaccins c'est ces gens qui
contestent tout servir du scientifique
le jeu revient sur les vaccins l'eau et
metz a annoncé il ya quinze jours
l'éradication de la polio en afrique
est ce que vous croyez que nous
n'aurions pu éradiquer la polio 100 le
vaccin
je suis rien d'autres mesures à prendre
donc je le dis comme scientifique
vacciner sait jamais un acte banal c'est
naturellement un acte médical et nous
leurrons quand le vaccin contre le corps
d'un virus sera au point nous l'espérons
dans un délai le plus proche possible
aurait encore ce débat le débat
les vaccins ont fait progresser la santé
publique mais c'est pas un acte banal
à ce titre on a appris ce matin
qu'astrazeneca mettait en pause c'est
ces tests sur les sur les vaccins est ce
qu'il faut s'attendre finalement à vivre
encore plusieurs années avec cette
menace avons rien parce que il ya dix
jours j'étais avec le
patron en france de sanofi qui annonçait
chacun des labos poursuit
j'allais dire la mise au point de ce
vaccin pour le deuxième trimestre de
l'année prochaine
la possibilité de mise sur le marché
d'un vaccin
je crois qu on aura des annonces parce
que ça allait bien la science l avance
parfois en bégayant c'est normal
dernière question sur ce sujet monsieur
le président il va y avoir un conseil de
défense vendredi
il ya un débat sur l'éventuelle
raccourcissement de la 14 n est ce que
pour vous il faut raccourcir cette 14ème
pour sentir la vie du scientifique
ça nous renvoie la biologie et en même
temps je pense que si on peut lever la
crainte de la longue durée on peut
faciliter le dépistage
donc si les scientifiques nous disent
7jours ça suffit on apparaît plus je lis
royalisme mais ça que médecin mais ça
pourrait lever un certain nombre de
prévention par que nous rencontrons tous
des gens qui les violent je vais pas me
faire dépister parce que je peux pas
m'arrêter 14 jours et je pense que vous
avez vu le premier ministre donne
l'exemple et moi-même tout vous avouer
c'est ce soir mon test à la crise
économique car la crise sociale qui
inquiète les français on va en parler
pour vous interroger sur ce sujet on
entendra eric berger de la dépêche du
midi le mari robin de ouest france mais
d'abord pour fait front pour faire face
à cette crise économique et sociale le
gouvernement a mis sur la table un plan
de relance d'un montant de 100 milliards
est-ce que pour vous les républicains
doivent voter ce plan de relance d'abord
ce sera le projet de loi de finances on
ne votera pas le plan de relance ce sera
à eux des éléments du projet de loi de
finances qui d'ailleurs posé frais
question comment antilles
dont le plan de relance parce que le
projet de loi de finances ne sera voté
qu'à la fin de l'année mais surtout
validé peut-être avec observation par le
conseil constitutionnel est en fait il
pourrait être mis effectivement en place
qu'au début de l'année or il ya des
besoins pour les entreprises il ya des
besoins pour notamment accompagné des
jeunes dans ce moment difficile il ya
des besoins pour la formation
professionnelle va y avoir des besoins
pour la transition écologique est trop
tard pour vous de l'agglo l'avions dit
au sénat souvenez vous au mois de
juillet au moment du projet de loi de
finances rectificative numéro 3 ça vous
dit il faut un premier volet mais
comment comment faire mais c'est la
pratique et par décret d'avancé
c'est aussi un des sujets sur lequel
j'ai échangé avec le premier ministre
le décret d'avancé ou savez c'est une
technique qui donne sept jours entre le
décret de sept jours pour que les
commissions des finances de leurs avis
et on peut ainsi anticiper moi ce qui
m'importe
au fond dans des orientations générales
qu'on peut partager que ce soit utile et
que ce soit efficace et ma grande
préoccupation c'est que on puisse
utiliser les moyens du plan de relance
et si on ne déconcentre pas une partie
de ce plan de relance au niveau des
territoires haut niveau par exemple des
régions et des départements
et nous aurons nous aurons de grandes
difficultés à mettre en oeuvre votre
crainte monsieur larcher sait que les
crédits ne soit pas consommée tout
simple bien sûr mais on le connaît avec
des crédits européens
donc il faut vraiment quelque chose qui
soit le plus proche des réalités des
entreprises des réalités ces référents
corps qui doit-il doit jouer son rôle
là dessus le préfet en dialogue avec les
élus en dialogue avec les organisations
professionnelles
c'est dans la proximité tous ne devra
pas être traité dans la proximité mais
sans avoir fait une analyse
financière absolue je disais au premier
ministre réellement
c'est ça la priorité pour que ça ne soit
pas simplement canal une annonce sur la
transition sur la compétitivité sur la
cohésion sociale on va avoir des besoins
sur la cohésion sociale oui avant la fin
de l'année et c'est là où il nous faut
des décret d'avancé et c'est au niveau
du terrain dans le dans le plan il est
un volet très fort d'implication des
territoires y compris financières or les
associés lui commence à lire attention
on veut bien mais il faut en avoir les
moyens bien sûr des compensations
comment vous le sénat qui est quand même
la chambre des territoires allait
veiller à ce que les collectivités les
moyens d'accompagner ce sera en débat
dans le projet de loi de finances ça
nous renvoie parce que le président de
la délégation collectivités
territoriales de l'assemblée nationale
avait chiffré la perte soit de recettes
soit les dépenses supplémentaires à la
fin juillet entre 3 milliards et 3
milliards et demi ici le rapporteur
général du budget parler de plus de 4
milliards
j'ai peur que ces chiffres du fait de la
continuation de la pandémie savez
j'étais à saint priest la semaine
dernière dans le rhône une école fermer
une classe fermée ça à des coûts pour
une collectivité locale et donc être
attentif par la réalité du bloc communal
en même temps nous vivons les
conséquences d'une décision auquel nous
nous sommes opposés que la taxe
d'habitation les communes vous récupérez
le foncier bâti des départements les
départements vont récupérer de la tva et
comme il ya les impôts de production
qu'il faut alléger qu'on appelle la cvae
j'allais dire l'héritière de la taxe
professionnelle faisons claire jeu qui
va aux régions va être diminuée
largement dit oui les craintes une bonne
assise et c'est une bonne décision mais
compensé par de la tva on va utiliser
des milliards de tva sur une collecte
annuelle de 180 milliards de tva
on est donc dans un bouleversement aussi
de la nature des recettes et du levier
fiscal alors en projet de loi de
finances pardonnez moi d'être un peu
technique
on a voté pour les départements une
garantie de recettes sur les droits de
mutation
on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de droits de
mutation le long des côtes mais qu'à
l'intérieur
voilà eh bien je pense que nous allons
suivre tout ça avec beaucoup d'attenté
sur les médias et les communes
particulièrement c'est l'association des
maires de france qui est peu satisfaite
de ce plan de relance et qui tire la
sonnette d'alarmé sur son autonomie
financière pour vous ce sont les
communes les grandes perdantes de ce
plan de relance et sont pas perdante
elle ne maîtrise pas suffisamment les
choses voilà que ça merde plus en danger
leur autonomie financière pour la belge
mais l'autonomie financière des
départements porte des mois à partir du
moment où il ya plus de levier fiscal du
foncier bâti
il n'y a pas que les communes les
départements sont aussi atteints voilà
pourquoi parallèlement nous allons
commencer cet automne avec un texte mais
on y reviendra tout à l'heure je crois
sur la différenciation et au printemps
la nouvelle génération décentralisation
dans lequel ea à l'autonomie financière
des collectivités et sur les
orientations monsieur larcher est ce que
finalement cette priorité la
souveraineté économique à la cohésion
sociale à la transition écologique
est-ce que c'est pas finalement un
projet que la droite aurait pu porter
elle même
d'abord les difficultés elles sont ni de
droite ni de gauche ni de en même temps
et donc ses réponses maintenant c'est
l'efficacité de la réponse et en même
temps de se poser partout du mois
d'utiliser ce que c'est un bon plan
monsieur larcher en fait c'est ni plus
ni moins que malgré ça ma question je
vous ai dit les orientations ricains
peuvent dire le plan de relance de
général sont bonnes je voulais dit en
préambule donc bâton c'est la mise en
oeuvre avec aussi une réalité est qu'un
jour c'est de l'argent c'est de la
monnaie qui n'est pas virtuel et qu'il
faudra tous à un moment le financer vous
avez perdu nos impôts non sexy blake le
gouvernement s'est engagé et je pense
que augmenter les impôts c'est porter
une atteinte à la compétitivité
on veut pas dire d'un côté je renforce
la compétitivité et de l'autre côté je
flingue la compétitivité mokrani est ce
que vous craignez que ça soit les
retraités qui paye l'a dit
non non puisqu'on a dit qu'il y avait
pas de hausse d'impôt alors on complète
parce que la crds va se prolonger par
exemple oui mais pour d'autres raisons
puisque je vous rappelle quand même une
chose on avait prévu autour de 93
milliards de déficit budgétaire pour
l'année 2020
nous serons autour de 260 milliards
également silva souvenir que le sénat
s'est arrêtée piégé l'an dernier pour
500 millions
autour du problème de l'hôpital on est
sur les comptes sociaux à plus de 40
milliards de déficit tout ça mérite
qu'on se pose un certain nombre de
questions et que nous envisagions une
fois j'allais dire la crise passée
comment on retrouve les équilibres et ça
c'est une vraie nécessité et une vraie
demande de la majorité sénatoriale et on
va parler de l'impact de cette crise sur
l'emploi on va aller dans une région
particulièrement touchée par cette crise
c'est la région toulousaine bonjour eric
berger merci d'être avec nous rédacteur
en chef adjoint de la dépêche du midi
vous avez une question pour gérard
larcher
oui bonjour henrianne bonjour monsieur
bon vous savez que toulouse et la région
toulousaine compte une filière
importante c'est la filière aéronautique
avec airbus
et puis de très nombreux sous traitants
qui sont fortement impactées par la
crise sanitaire et la crise dans
l'aéronautique
alors au début de l'été le gouvernement
l'état a annoncé un plan de soutien
important à la filière avec près de 15
milliards d'euros d'euros dont une bonne
partie il faut le dire quand même
consacré à air france est-ce que vous
pensez que cette réponse est à la
hauteur de cette crise et qu'on peut
sauver notre notre filière et
aéronautique et surtout les emplois il
faut sauver la filière aéronautique dont
je rappelle qu'elle est dans notre
balance commerciale
la première des éléments positifs de
notre balance commerciale s'est
naturellement créateurs d'emplois et
créateur de souveraineté à un moment on
parle beaucoup de souveraineté j'ai reçu
eux s'est longuement le président
d'airbus à la fin du mois de juillet
pour examiner avec lui les éléments de
d'un plan de soutien
parce que ça n'est pas une crise pour
six mois
c'est pas une crise pour un an le cycle
qui semblent engagés et plus tôt ainsi
que sur trois années et que il apparaît
très important qu'on puisse faire le
point voilà pourquoi la commission des
affaires économiques qui d'ailleurs dont
la présidente assisté à cet entretien va
mettre en place un suivi pour cette
filière aéronautique et pour la sous
traitance de la filière aéronautique
savez j'étais en seine-maritime lundi
qui est et la région normandie c'est
naturellement pas la région toulousaine
ni l'occitanie mais c'est le troisième
bassin impacté le troisième bassin en
importance dans le domaine aéronautique
il ya un certain nombre de signaux qui
sont des signaux inquiétants
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'au
sénat nous allons mettre en place et il
est déjà mis en place un suivi pour la
filière aéronautique et pour les emplois
de cette filière je pense que si on
retire les moyens qui sont consacrés à
air france il faudra peut-être quelques
quelques compléments si nécessaire et il
faudra ajuster le plan il va pas être
définitif il doit s'ajuster aussi aux
réalités et me semble-t-il
le débat parlementaire sera utile sur ce
sujet j'aurais pu compléter la question
d'erick si je prends la seule journée
d'hier on a eu les annonces la
cristallerie baccarat en lorraine
jacob delafon en franche comté
bénéteau dans l'ouest bio c'est bon de
partout en france ce sont des marques
connues toutes ont annoncé des plans
sociaux
hier donc on voit le scénario qui
ressemble très fort à celui de 2008 et
même peut-être encore plus fort
donc quelle réponse apporter à la fois
les territoires qui vont être sinistrées
et à ses salariés vous avez été ministre
du travail
vous avez bien connu ce situation donc
comment on fait d'abord ce que ce que
vous annoncez malheureusement la liste
ne va pas s'arrêter
et moi qui fait les déplacements depuis
la fin du mois d'août
je pourrais vous parler dans le
finistère de notre inquiétude porté
d'ailleurs par un sénateur paul qui
m'avait interrogé sur brittany ferries
il va en parler arrivants palabrer et
ses réalités là nécessite j'allais dire
un suivi particulier
voilà pourquoi je crois qu'il est très
important que le parlement puisse
accompagner et suivre
très concrètement le ministre du travail
que j'ai été dès qu'il faut réagir par
filière par bassin d'emploi et voir en
même temps comment on gaspille pas
pardonné mois les ressources humaines
les compétences l'aéronautique c'est
l'exemple même de grandes compétences
qui sont dans une industrie
j'allais dire la sous traitance aussi et
comment les gaspille pas d'où les plans
de formation d'où les accords
d'activités adaptées en temps de travail
en moyens l'ensemble des essais donc
avec les partenaires sociaux qu'il faut
en même temps
traverser cette période difficile mais
ces marchés est ce qu'il faut s'attendre
comme le président d'ailleurs l'avait
noté à une énorme casse sociale et
industrielle
je pense que nous avons le risque d'une
densité de sinistres industriels dans un
certain nombre de secteurs je ne nie pas
que le casque de sinistres industriels
le secteur de l'automobile même si psa
se porte mieux que renault
je ne peux pas vous dire moi l'élu des
yvelines
je ne suis pas inquiet par le sinistre
renault dans la vallée de la seine avec
des conséquences sociales assez
terrifiante dans un territoire qui
souffre depuis des années est donc nous
pouvons avoir une période extrêmement
difficile
voilà pourquoi dans cette période il
suffit pas de se montrer du doigt
mutuellement faut essayer d'aider porter
notre pays vous parliez de brittany
ferries monsieur le président justement
va en parler avec yves marie robin
journaliste à ouest france depuis rennes
bon
yves marie vous avez une question à ce
sujet bonjour bonjour monsieur merchet
bonjour effectivement la bretagne doit
affronter une grave crise économique en
ce moment dans les côtes d'armor un plan
social chez nec nokia avec 400 emplois
touchés une fermeture la compagnie
d'aviation en europe à morlaix d'ici
deux ans avec 200 emplois concernés et
puis donc maintenant effectivement vous
disiez la compagnie navigation brittany
ferries à roscoff face à l'île de batz
vous connaissez bien je crois cette
entreprise de 2000 à 3000 salariés selon
les saisons spécialisé donc dans les
traversées vers l'angleterre est
doublement victime du bric site est
forcément du coc vide ces pertes sont
chiffrées actuellement à 100 millions
d'euros cette direction en appelle à
l'état les a dit très inquiète notamment
les sénateurs que faire donc pour lui
éviter de sombrer alors avec d'abord
j'ai vu le président roues et il ya une
dizaine de jours avec le président de la
commission pour l'union européenne parce
que il ya le sujet briques site vous
avez raison et sur le lac au vite vous
avez la décision britannique de la
quarantaine mais aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui brittany ferries ne
transporte que 10 % des passagers qu'il
transportait
auparavant il ne suffira pas de mesures
d'exemption fiscale et sociale
rien que le prêt garanti par l'état
aujourd'hui quand il entrera dans sa
phase de remboursement
c'est au moins la somme des exemptions
fiscales et sociales
je pense que nous sommes là sur le
premier armements français utilisant le
plus de marins français
c'est une affaire de souveraineté
maritime il faut donc traiter le sujet
de manière adaptée pour la brittany
ferries ça touche la bretagne ça touche
la normandie et ça touche tout à circuit
économique qui parle fret permet
d'échanger avec les îles britanniques
c'est donc un sujet pour rien vous
cacher hier conjointement le président
de la commission pour l'union européenne
et moi même avons saisi le premier
ministre c'était d'ailleurs un
sujet d'entretien d'il ya dix jours avec
le premier ministre la question de la
brittany ferries vous avez évoqué up
sujet très important pour morlaix car
c'est l'héritage brit air et derrière il
ya la formation mais il ya la
maintenance est donc ce sujet il est
réellement posé dans la situation où
europe mais il est il a été posé mais
qu'est ce que vous a répondu le premier
ministre
il tentera examiné de vous parler
brittany ferries way up with a fairy
britannique hier il est en train
d'examiner le dossier
et n'oubliez m'ont fait des propositions
mais laissons premier ministre quand
même quelques temps on n'est pas dans
l'exigence qui m'importe c'est la
situation des territoires bretons
normands des salariés et de l'entreprise
et de la souveraineté maritime
car la question de la souveraineté
maritime est posée un mot sur nokia
j'ai aussi reçu des nokia en juillet
parce que tout ça nous inquiète le
territoire de lannion n'en finit pas
d'être impactée j'espère qu'il y aura
des annonces positives donc quelques
jours pour le secteur de lannion pour
rencontrant la présidente de la
communauté de communes du finistère
juste en limite des côtes d'armor
elle me disait l'inquiétude des citoyens
qui travaillent dans le bassin d'emploi
de lannion et qui aujourd'hui ne cesse
de voir ce cas était un des fleurons du
développement de la france est breton
autour de la téléphonie en train de dalé
d'attrition d'attrition
merci yves marie on vous retrouve un
petit peu plus tard dans cette émission
va passer à un autre sujet gérard
larcher c'est la sécurité le séparatisme
qui sont les thèmes de rentrée du
gouvernement un séminaire gouvernemental
à d'ailleurs lieu sur ces questions de
sécurité aujourd'hui est ce que vous
dites que le gouvernement a mis trop de
temps à s'attaquer à ces questions et
que les élus locaux
finalement on était laissé trop seul
l'insécurité c'est pas un sentiment
c'est une réalité
et moi je dépasse les mots et je ne vais
même pas évoqué un livre de tradition
indienne qui traduit est plutôt le
bonheur
que le malheur comme le président de la
république par contre c'est vrai qu'il
ya une banalisation de la violence mais
nos concitoyens n'en peuvent plus de la
violence votre confrère le monde cité
bressuire qui ne passe pas allez dire
pour un secteur violent les images de
grenoble les images de toulouse
ce qu'on a vu sur les champs elysées
mais aussi tout simplement ce qui m'a
été racontée à nîmes vendredi dernier
qui fait que le maire de nîmes a demandé
rendez vous au ministre de l'intérieur
c'est un territoire dans lequel il ya eu
un effort très le continuum de sécurité
engagés avec l'état mais qui est dans
une situation très difficile mais
montant vers alès la commune de fontanès
des élus agressé une insécurité dont il
s'agit aujourd'hui apporter une réponse
à ceux qui ont dit souvenez vous il ya
dix jours à la droite s'empare de ce
dossier le gouvernement s'en rend
tellement content qu'il y consacre
aujourd'hui un séminaire et kellé
consacre me semble-t-il
moi je pense qu'il faut réfléchir au
continuum de sécurité on nous promet
depuis deux ans un livre blanc sur la
sécurité
je les rappelle d'ailleurs premier
ministre premiers pas en l'état le
projet de quand même je reprends des
mots qui ne m'appartiennent pas qui
était à l'exécutif à un monument de
technocratie il faut donc qu'on fasse
concret je pense qu'il faut qu'on le
sorte ce livre blanc est que ce livre
blanc dans le continuum il doit partir
du maire première acteurs de la sécurité
et qu'il aille jusqu'à la réponse pénale
et à l'exécution de la peine
il ne suffit pas de mobiliser policiers
gendarmes policiers municipaux dans ce
couple d'ailleurs préfet berre il faut
aussi derrière et on l'a longtemps nié
que la réponse judiciaire soit à la
hauteur donc plus sévères qu'aujourd'hui
pas simplement puisse se faire il faut
plus de magistrats est plus impliqué les
rouges
j'ai changé avec le procureur général et
il me disait les piles de dossiers qui
aujourd'hui entre la grève des avocats
le confinement l'augmentation d'un été
qui a été très difficile sur les côtes
très difficile en matière de sécurité
la difficulté qu'ils apporteraient pause
il me disait la priorité c'est d'avoir
des greffiers la priorité c'est d'avoir
des magistrats mais encore plus des
greffiers voyez que quand on va sur le
territoire on prend la température quand
un procureur général vous dis cela vous
ne pouvez pas ne pas le prendre en
compte et je pense que ce sera une des
demandes pour ce continuum de sécurité
on va retourner à toulouse pour parler à
de ces questions toulouse qui a été
touchée avec eric berger oui en effet
vous avez cité toulouse
effectivement depuis le début de l'été
dans les quartiers de toulouse
principalement les quartiers nord il ya
eu près d'une dizaine de fusillades qui
ont fait cinq victimes
alors c'est principalement des affaires
liées au trafic de stupéfiants
toutefois ça participe de du sentiment
d'insécurité alors si elle peut être
réalité oui quelqu'un peut être qu'elle
peut être la réponse de l'état enfin
vous l'avais un peu évoquée est ce que
c'est qu'une question de d'effectifs de
police a renforcé sur le sur le terrain
sachant en tous les cas pour le pea
spécifique de toulouse que c'est quand
même principalement liée au trafic de
stupéfiants
toulouse et je pense au quartier des
izards tout à fait récemment c'est
naturellement l'installation de
territoires qui sont allés mis hors de
la république dans lequel la république
au fond quoi qu'on en dise n'a pas
totalement axé dans lequel les habitants
dans leur immense majorité subissent
la violence de ceux qui ont organisé le
quartier avec une complication part de
mémoire de le dire entre guillemets
parce que c'est assez horrible de le
dire ainsi liées à la perturbation de la
fermeture des frontières avec l'espagne
et le maroc
vous avez donc des enjeux majeurs dans
le trafic de drogue
il faut que la république soit partout
chez elle c'est naturellement policiers
c'est naturellement la présence sur le
terrain et c'est d'aller au bout au bout
et notamment bout en matière judiciaire
et pénal il ya un certain nombre
d'observations souvenez vous en avez
créé les groupes d'intervention
régionaux l'hégire en matière de trafic
et a maintenant plus d'une dizaine
d'années il ya des réponses à apporter
c'est pour ça que nous avons besoin de
ce livre blanc sur la sécurité parce
qu'on doit définir on doit définir
l'objectif on doit définir la stratégie
est derrière cela me semble-t-il
il faut aussi redéfinir un concept du
maintien de l'ordre
si le concept de maintien de l'ordre
c'est on préfère des vitrines cassées à
l'ordre établi et bien je crois que nous
aurons de grandes difficultés à l'heure
actuelle c'est ce que vous pensez c'est
que c'est vous dire qu'à une retenue
dans les forces de l'ordre qu'on n'est
pas là on n'a pas l'impression qu'ils
soient particulièrement en retenue
écoutez vous regardez les champs-elysées
vous voyez les arbitrages qui sont faits
certains disent vous pensez que ça les
forces de l'ordre doivent taper plus
fort qu'elles doivent assurer l'ordre
l'ordre républicain
or nous avons vous aurez dans quelques
semaines le travail de la délégation
collectivités locales du sénat sur le
rapport d'étape sur ce livre blanc et
vous verrez que la doctrine d'emploi des
forces de l'ordre elle est interrogée et
date il ya très très longtemps
cette doctrine d'emploi certains la
forme monte à 68 d'autres au drame de la
mort de malik oussékine donc c'est pas
un sujet
il faut traiter comme sans violence et
j'allais dire en agitant ses bras mais
il y a un problème de doctrine d'emploi
il ya aussi un problème il faut que le
pays soutienne ces policiers ces
gendarmes
vous pensez que c'est pas le cas mais je
pense que les français sur le fond mais
parfois et sur un certain nombre de
sujets qui méritent sans doute des
réactions voire des sanctions
on en fait une généralité la république
a besoin de ceux qui assurent le respect
de la loi la défense de l'état de droit
il s'appelle policiers gendarmes il
s'appelle juges qu'ils soient procureur
magistrat du simple et plus généralement
le miz intérieur parlé d'un soulagement
de la société la délinquance un
phénomène extrême + 16 % de violences
aux personnes non mais il ya aussi le
refus de l'institution du maire du
professeur parfois de me des parents
donc la réponse d'hôtel pas être plus
global bien sûr les questions
d'éducation
la question aussi d'appartenance à une
communauté nationale qu'ont fait
partager et on le voit bien il ya du
séparatisme
écoutez il ya un sondage qui démontrait
que plus des deux tiers des jeunes
compatriotes musulmans de moins de 25
ans pensait que la loi religieuse était
supérieure à la loi de la république est
le premier des sujets dans le
séparatiste et de réaffirmer le principe
que la république c'est une communauté
nationale que dans notre pays un de ses
fondements
c'est la laïcité à côté du fondement de
l'école j'avais là on vient de fêter le
150e anniversaire de la république
pour moi il ya quatre piliers dans la
république d'or de la démocratie
la commune on est dans les lois de la
fin du 19e l'assemblée communale
délibère l'école là
et qu'est né ici dans cette assemblée
l'école la loi de 1901 qui permet
l'association des citoyens autour d'un
projet et la loi de 1905
je rappelle ces mots de brillants ils
sont actuels la loi doit protéger la foi
et je suis très attentif à ce que chacun
puisse exercer ou ne pas exercer son
culte de croire ne pas croire mais
poursuivent et brillant la foi ne doit
jamais dicter la loi
je crois que c'est tout simple il faut
le rappeler est un certain nombre de
mesures que le gouvernement s'apprête de
3 à proposer j'ai écrit avec un
philosophe marcel gauchet un petit
ouvrage c'était il ya un an autour de la
loi de 1905 qui était une réflexion en
profondeur
non pas pour dire qu'elle était
intouchable mais pour dire qu'elle était
au fondement de la république et à
mesure excuse-moi oriane les premières
mesures qui et qui ont trait à la au
projet de loi de lutte contre les
séparatismes par exemple de faire du
site signé une charte aux associations
vous pensez que ça va ça va s'élancer un
des éléments mais naturellement au delà
de 2 2 se lasser de réaffirmer que la
république démocratiquement choisies et
les lois de la république sont
supérieurs aux rois rôle aux lois
religieuses et quel que soit j'allais
dire les religions il ya des dérives à
caractère sectaire en quelque sorte oui
on en parlait il ya une quinzaine
d'années beaucoup et par exemple quand
nous avons fait ici la loi sur l'école
proposé notamment par françoise gatel
une élue bretonne et qui visait à
contrôler les écoles hors contrat leurs
vertus rats les accompagner c'était une
réponse aux risques on a de repli sur
soi même dans la formation des enfants
qui doivent être formés aux valeurs de
la république
nous avons en partage et voir ce qui va
être sans doute proposé pour les
associations qui assurent un certain
nombre de cours de langues ou
d'associations culturelles qui en fait
on saigne la religion ça doit être
possible mais ça doit être possible
autour des valeurs de la république et
il y a aussi des sujets sur lequel on ne
peut pas transiger c'est l'égalité
hommes-femmes le débat autour de la
polygamie débat autour de ces certificat
de virginité
nous devons dans la république et c'est
une conquête qui n'est pas venue de la
troisième république qui s'est
construite progressivement l'égalité
hommes-femmes est intransigeante
un dernier mot sur ce sujet monsieur le
président puisque on va passer aux
questions des élus locaux et territoires
les maires qui sont victimes de
nombreuses agressions on va voir les
chiffres 360 est une agression 2018 383
en 2019 et déjà 233 en 2020 le garde des
sceaux eric dupond moretti a fait
paraître une circulaire en début de
semaine qui demande aux procureurs de
durcir les poursuites à l'encontre des
agresseurs d'élus locaux est ce que pour
vous cette circulaire est suffisante
je crois que c'est une décision qui
était nécessaire que nous avions demandé
engagement et proximité le débat a lieu
quatre mois après le drame de signes
j'étais à signer j'ai vu beaucoup d'élus
la commission des lois ici au sénat sous
l'impulsion de philippe bas à lancer une
enquête
vous savez la réalité c'est que la
majorité des élus ne portait même pas
plainte que l'immense majorité des
dossiers été classée sans suite
nous avons demandé et avançait
d'ailleurs d'engagement de proximité
mais pas suffisamment notamment la
protection fonctionnelle de l'élu elle
doit pouvoir être prises sans même
délibération du conseil municipal
l'accompagnement par l'état d'une
cellule qui accompagne dans le
département la violence qui est faite à
un élu j'ai vécu ça dans mon département
dimanche soir un décès du doyen et est
malmené la cellule départementale a
fonctionné croyez moi
c'est un élément important et puis on ne
peut pas continuer à avoir des
classements sans suite sans explication
ou de simple rappel à la loi
le maire délégué de portbail qui est
violente et à simple rappel à la loi
ça n'est pas j'allais dire à la hauteur
je rappelle que l'élu délégué il est
dépositaire d'une part d'autorités
publiques et tout à l'heure ça nous
renvoie la république aux séparatistes
ça nous renvoie aussi au respect y
compris dans les quartiers que nous
évoquions à toulouse je pense que c'est
extrêmement important
ça nous aidera aussi à retrouver des
repères parce que je dis à monsieur
jalabert nous avons un problème de
repères dans la société aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de repères se sont
effacées sans être remplacés par
d'autres
et certains repères je pense aux repères
religieux qui devrait être un repaire de
construction voilà pourquoi je pense que
l'islam est compatible avec la
république
mais à la condition que ce soit
cet islam qui partage la république et
permet à ceux qui ont la foi dans cette
religion de l'exercer paisiblement dans
une république française dont ils sont
des éléments allez on va parler des
questions de territoire des questions
d'élus locaux le sénat qui a fait 50
propositions pour une nouvelle
décentralisation c'était début juillet
c'est vous même qui les qui les avait
présentés
quel retour vous avez eu depuis de la
part du gouvernement est ce que vous
savez celle qui vont être prises
d'abord dans son discours de politique
générale le premier ministre a utilisé
comme le psalmiste des dizaines de fois
le mot territoire
donc je lui ai dit il ya aucune malice
mais quand même avec un clin d'oeil on
passe aux travaux pratiques est passé
aux travaux pratiques c'est quoi c'est
d'abord pour nous et a priori c'est au
cours du mois d'octobre ont entamé la
discussion des propositions de loi
qu'ils sont issus des 50
proposition que l'ensemble notamment des
présidents groupes politiques ont adopté
sur le rapport de jean marie bockel et
de philippe bas les ppl les propositions
de loi ont été déposées fin juillet une
constitutionnel sur l'autonomie
financière des collectivités locales
une autre sur le fond sur la
décentralisation
le premier ministre m'a fait savoir que
le texte sur la différenciation c'est à
dire la possibilité de gérer des
territoires d'une manière qui soit
adaptée à la réalité territoriale
seraient examinées au cours de l'automne
nous avons des propositions d'autant
plus que le président de la république
en nous demandant la contribution plan
de relance le sénat a fait deux
contributions ses cinquante propositions
sur lequel il a travaillé depuis des
mois bien avant l'épidémie de covin et
une autre proposition qui est venue du
président de la commission des affaires
sociales alain milon sur la santé parce
qu'on en parle moins aujourd'hui
il n'empêche que vous n'avons pas résolu
simplement par des crédits ou par le
ségur l'hospital aux centristes
la présence médicale sur le territoire
la manière de fonctionner de redonner
confiance dans notre système de santé et
donc je pense moi personnellement que
sur ces sujets là nous devons apporter
les réponses
elle est justement va parler de ces
questions de décentralisation va aller à
poitiers retrouver baptiste hobbies
journalistes à la nouvelle république
dont jean baptiste on écoute votre
question oui bonjour bienvenue à
poitiers au petit aujourd'hui ça en
quelque sorte la capitale de la france
c'est en tout cas la ville d'arrivée de
l'étape du jour du tour de france c'est
formidable on est ravis d'autant que ce
n'était pas arrivé depuis très longtemps
mais ça ne nous fait pas oublier que
poitiers ex capitale de l'ex région
poitou charentes éprouve depuis cinq ans
un sentiment persistant de déclassement
alors cinq ans après le gouvernement
nous proposera vous proposera vous venez
de le rappeler une réforme territoriale
a minima en 2021
ici dans une région dont on a fait de
bordeaux une capitale hyper jacobine
on va suivre ces questions très
attentivement pensez-vous première
question qu'un nouvel acte fort de
décentralisation aurait été une bonne
réponse aux lourdeurs de l'état que la
crise sanitaire a révélé au printemps
et puis deuxième question vous venez de
dire vous étiez favorable à
l'introduction de la différenciation
entre les territoires
jusqu'où faut-il aller dans les
expérimentations à la carte
la nouvelle aquitaine par exemple elle
souhaite prendre la main sur la
politique de l'emploi
peut-on envisager de confier la santé ou
même l'éducation à certaines régions je
poursuis les changes que j'avais un
corium nancy ni sur ce sujet je n'ai
parlé que de la différenciation mais au
printemps le gouvernement s'est engagé à
ce qu on parle de décentralisation de
manière très concrète et dans les 50
propositions que nous faisons nous avons
pas simplement la question de la
différenciation
c'est la gestion territoriale adapté et
pour répondre à votre question sur la
santé par exemple
nous pensons nous proposons je le dis si
nous avons la même majorité sénatoriale
nous voterons le principe que les
agences régionales de santé soit présidé
dans chaque région par le président de
la région nous proposerons aux
débattront et nous voterons le fait que
sur le plan médico social pour le plan
médico social eh bien ça soit le
département et le président du conseil
de département nous proposons de mettre
en place des conférences départementales
de la santé nous proposerons sur les
sujets environnementaux aussi je pense à
des agences très centralisé à ce que ça
soit le retour sur le territoire de
d'éléments forts notamment de
l'indispensable transition écologique
vraiment je crois qu'il faut que
portions à connaissance partout de nos
cinquante propositions elles sont très
concrètes pour répondre à la question
que vous posez de ces grandes régions
parce que le le sujet il peut être posé
dans votre région pour tout vous dire je
l' ai quand même entendu et pas qu'à
poitiers posé ce sujet ce qu'un sujet
que les élus sur la manière de
s'organiser devront traiter au niveau de
leur territoire régional
voilà pourquoi nous proposons une
liberté d'organisation dont chacun des
territoires entre régions départements
communautés de communes et communes ne
plus être dans un carcan hérité de
textes dont la loi sur la nouvelle
organisation les territoriales de la
république ou la loi sur les métropoles
beaucoup plus de liberté beaucoup plus
de souplesse beaucoup plus d'initiatives
messieurs larcher simple simple question
parce que pour les personnes qui
comprendrait pas la différenciation va
permettre évidemment de deux
d'expérimenter beaucoup d'organisation
mais ce qu'on n'est pas en allant trop
loin dans cet air expiré expérimentation
est ce qu'on risque pas de porter
atteinte à l'unité de la république
coûtait un gaulliste comme moi est très
attentif à l'unité la république
on vient de parler du séparatisme
seraient eux attention à tous les
séparatismes quel qu'il soit je ne crois
pas si j'allais vers vous êtes dans une
région qui a connu la naissance de la
collectivité territoriale d'alsace
départements qui sont une ombre et et et
je pense que c'est possible et nous
l'avons voté ici en y ayant mis un
certain nombre de garde-fous
mais dans un débat qui a permis
d'approfondir
il faut que nous puissions avoir des
organisations de cette nature qui nous
permettent d'avancer
je me souviens bien de la rapporteure
qui est une élue de seine maritime du
arbres agnès canayer
je lui dis au moins vous êtes à 1000
kilomètres de strasbourg
mais au fond je crois que la république
une et indivisible n'est pas
antagoniques
il n'ya pas d'antagonisme profond à des
organisations adapté nous le voyons bien
entre métropole et et villes
intermédiaires villes moyennes
ce qu'on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui on croit
qu'on est 1-1 indivisible et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
villes moyennes notamment souffre du
poids des métropoles cas certain nombre
de communes
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on n'a pas
reproduit les petits paris en fait un
peu partout j'entends des bordeaux et
bordeaux
les petits pas quand vous évoquez le
jacobinisme bordelais c'est un risque
je vois d'autres régions qui ont été
recomposés où le sentiment n'est pas
tout à fait le même
parce qu'il ya des modes d'organisation
qui a vraiment centraliser toutes les
directions décentralisées de l'état à
bordeaux rien après le cas dans toutes
les régions effectivement je m'adresse à
vous pour vous dire que on a beaucoup
parlé de décentralisation mais je
voudrais vous parler de déconcentration
de l'état au fond depuis dix ans les
préfets de département depuis 10 ans ont
perdu la plupart de l'autorité sur leur
sur les services de l'état tout ça s'est
transformé dans dix agences de manière
extrêmement lointaine il faut
d'écocentres est déconcentré l'état pour
favoriser la proximité le dialogue est
le préfet à poitiers doit retrouver des
pouvoirs qu'il a perdu merci beaucoup
merci mathis tubize d'avoir été un autre
sujet c'est le sujet de la droite gérard
larcher et pour commencer ce thème on va
retourner à rennes retrouve et
yves-marie robin
re bonjour il y un peu plus d'un an
monsieur l'archet après l'échec des
européennes
et puis le départ de laurent wauquiez
vous preniez un peu votre bâton de
pèlerin pour tenter de recoller les
morceaux de la droite y êtes vous
parvenu ou est-ce mission impossible
compte tenu des divisions internes
d'abord en jeu
2010neuf après les européennes
souvenez vous dans quel état étaient les
familles de droite et du centre je pense
personnellement je pense dans l'intérêt
du pays qu'il y à un espace politique
entre la république en marche et le
rassemblement national que nous devons
occuper car nous sommes la seule force
d'alternative crédible aujourd'hui je ne
me préoccupe pas de la gauche mais je
pense que la question se pose à gauche
de la même manière et donc occuper cet
espace
ça a été ma première préoccupation dans
ces conventions que vous évoquez que
j'ai conduit l'été l'automne dernier
nous sommes aujourd'hui la première
formation territoriale la famille des
républicains avec nos alliés du centre
et les personnalités indépendantes
cette réalité là démontre que les
valeurs que nous portons notre vision de
la société notre vision de la société au
travers du quotidien des citoyens et des
territoires
elle est partagée mais depuis l'échec à
l'élection présidentielle dans les
conditions qu'on sait je le dis tout de
suite c'est pas la primaire qui nous a
fait échouer mais c'est un certain
nombre de difficultés rencontrées par
notre candidat certain nombre inouï
fallu attendre mais par notre candidat à
ce moment là qu'ils ont valu notre échec
et nous n'avons pas encore retrouvé
cette dimension j'allais dire du
perspective nationale c'est donc ce à
quoi nous devons travailler alors dans
cette vème république qui vous est cher
en effet il faut au programme une ligne
politique mais il faut aussi l'incarner
alors il ya des prétendants mais ils
sont pas d'accord sur la façon de
choisir le candidat valérie pécresse
bruno retailleau 10 primaire christian
jacob le patron des républicains il n'en
veut pas
xavier bertrand dit moi non plus après
verser les régionales comment désigner
celui qui va incarner cette droite de
façon on va dire saint jean
j'ai pas ce que ça veut dire sagement
mais je rassemble ça doit être dans la
vème république
naturellement l'élection soubassement
c'est l'élection présidentielle
l'élection qui est aussi un autre
soubassement du quotidien j'essaie des
élections territoriales et de l'élection
municipale
face à cela parce que nous ne pourrons
pas faire de grandes réformes dans les
20 mois qui viennent d'abord falloir
qu'on sorte de la crise sanitaire de la
crise de confiance parce qu'au fond
notre pays à la fois locaux vides et
autres virus lui qui n'a pas de vaccin
qui s'appelle la confiance la crise des
gilet jaune
moi je n'ai pas oublié c'est une crise
de confiance la crise sur
l'indispensable réforme des retraites
qui nous amène en février souvenez-vous
dans le même conseil des ministes parlé
pour la première fois de la pandémie et
en même temps votre 49 3 nous sommes
toujours sous le 49-3 tout cela la
confiance nous devons la rétablir et je
ne vois que l'élection présidentielle
pourrait un moment où nous pouvons
engager le train de réformes nécessaires
dans notre pays a besoin
vous dites il faut une candidate ou un
candidat pour occuper cet espace et pour
proposer aux français
est ce que vous voulez voter pour la
république en marche et celui qu'il
incarne en l'occurrence le président de
la république ou est ce que vous voulez
un autre projet une autre politique
incarné par un homme mais comment
choisir un candidat
ces notes c'est sur ce sujet comme vous
le savez je ne fais pas partie de ceux
qu'on dit les primaires sont la cause de
nos malheurs donc on fait pas la machine
à perdre et c'est ça que vous disent
sans doute nous ne pouvons plus
organiser les primaires comme nous les
avons organisé pour différentes raisons
y compris logistiques et financières
aussi qu'on se dise les choses
voilà pourquoi j'ai un jour après en
avoir débattu g
posez qu'il y ait une méthode de
départage hier comité stratégique
il a été décidé que la procédure
concrètes seraient mises en oeuvre après
ce qui doit être notre priorité vers les
élections départementales et les
élections régionales mais que d'ici là
un groupe de travail pouvait préparer
des partages et comme j'ai dit que je
prendrai mes responsabilités je les
prendrai ou si on me propose de les
propres pour vous présiderez ce groupe
je n'en sais rien il appartient
christian jacob je lui fais totalement
confiance
mais j'ai entendu il n'ya pas position à
mon avis un compatible wii savez j'ai
vécu ce que j'appelle le syndrome de
l'escalator
comme nous nous sommes retrouvés pour
éviter ce qui apparaît c'est que pour
certains comme une débandade
je pense qu avec sagesse détermination
c'est à devoir
j'ai dit à port marly que je ne
laisserai pas faire n'importe quoi
donc je vais il redit mais c'est quoi
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi ce serait
d'avoir deux candidats au premier tour
c'est la certitude de ne pas être au
second tour ce serait une faute contre
la démocratie à un mot sur celui que
beaucoup espéraient comme votre candidat
ans françois baroin alors il a dit qu'il
ferait connaître sa décision à l'automne
est ce qu'il vous en a fait part de
cette décision nous parce qu'il n'a pas
encore prise en tant que tel qu'est ce
qui l'attend parce que je pense que il
faut bien qu'on se dise tout à l'heure
vous faisiez la liste de ce qui se
profile au plan économique social et
sociétal
dans quel état seront nous dans deux
mois dans deux mois et demi la première
préoccupation le nos concitoyens je le
vois en déplaçant s'est pas d'abord
l'élection présidentielle c'est un débat
forte intéressante vous les partis
politiques et qu'on ne doit pas éluder
ya pas le quotidien
1 et les inquiétudes des gens c'est je
suis jeune dans ma propre permanence qui
est ouverte six jours sur sept
je n'ai jamais vu dans une région qui va
bien autant de jeunes venir nous
chercher pour un stage pour une
alternance donc c'est ça le quotidien
s'ils ne l'a pas encore prise vous avez
dit tout le bien que vous pensez de
françois baroin est ce que vous allez
tenter de le convaincre d'être votre
candidat je pense du bien de françois
baroin je pense du bien de valérie
pécresse je serai demain avec xavier
bertrand et vous le savez avec bruno
retailleau la relation que nous pouvons
avoir avec parfois notre diversité
je pense qu'on a une addition de talents
et que mon rêve c'est plutôt légers tous
ces acquis pour 3 bruno retailleau qui a
déjà un fait part de sa volonté d'être
candidat est ce qu'il est à même de
rassembler la droite et le centre c'est
votre volonté de rassembler
quel sens je constate ce qu'il fait ici
au sénat
quand je constate ce que fait la
majorité sénatoriale
quand je vois sur des sujets très
sensibles comme les questions de
bioéthique où chacun connaît les
positions qui sont les siennes
il démontre qu'il est en capacité
d'écouté et de partage et de respecter
les différences c'est un président de
groupe
je vous le dis devant vous exceptionnel
on va parler des sénatoriales je veux
juste remercier yves-marie robin de
ouest france d'avoir été avec nous on va
parler des sénatoriales alors je le
précise gérard larcher en le sénat est
renouvelé par moitié vous n'êtes pas
renouvelables cette cette fois-ci vous
avez déjà annoncé votre intention d'être
à nouveau candidat à la présidence du
sénat et pour cela il va vous falloir
conforté en tout cas stabiliser votre
majorité présidentielle la droite qui a
perdu aux municipales des grandes villes
comme marseille comme bordeaux est ce
que vous craignez un affaiblissement de
notre majorité
d'abord la majorité sénatoriale par
rassembler dans cette élection
ce rassemblement ça veut pas dire que
dans un certain nombre de départements
il n'y a pas plusieurs listes mais ils
se rassemblent autour d'une conception
de la représentation des territoires de
la vitalité de la démocratie de
l'amélioration de la fabrique de la loi
ils se rassemblent autour de la force
des territoires de la confiance dans la
proximité ça c'est le projet de la
majorité sénatoriale
alors je pense que nous allons vers des
perspectives je l'espère de stabilité de
la majorité sénatoriale avec un
renouveau assez profond je suis frappée
je me livre pas partout mais à un petit
test dans les réunions avec les délégués
sénatoriaux aujourd'hui pour respecter
les conditions sanitaires à des plus le
même style de réunion mais je leur pose
la question qui a déjà voté pour
l'élection des sénateurs est en général
entre 30 à 40 5 % des mains se lèvent
ça veut dire que de l'autre côté il y en
a qui n'ont jamais voté pour l'élection
sénatoriale
il est donc important de comprendre qu
est ce qu une élection sénatoriale c'est
au travers des élus territoriaux ils
sont 550 milles dans ce pays de choisir
les représentants d'une des deux
chambres du parlement pour représenter
du territoire mais aussi pour voter la
loi pour contrôler le gouvernement en
matière de contrôle de gouvernement de
démontrer notre efficacité
donc nous serons les conséquences des
élections municipales à marseille les
écologistes ont gagné à marseille
et pourtant paris bouches du rhône après
une période quand même terrible de
divisions nous nous sommes retrouvés au
tour de l'élection sénatoriale la
majorité autour de patrick bauret il y
aura des conséquences bien sûr à lyon il
y aura des conséquences sans doute plus
importante à bordeaux parce que les
réalités mais nous avons du candidat et
vous savez les délégués sénatoriaux
parfois ils dépassent les simples
clivages partisans
maintenant on va parler des sénatoriales
avec sébastien cours à temps journaliste
à l'écho républicain bonjour sébastien
merci d'être avec nous et vous avez des
questions à gérard larcher sur cette
élection
bonjour oriane bonjour monsieur larcher
alors je vous venez d'évoquer
l'hypothèse que qui est plusieurs listes
l air ou à l'air compatible dans
certains territoires c'est le cas en
eure et loir avec les sénatoriales qui
se présente un peu comme un duel à
distance entre les deux écuries
politiques principal du département vous
préférez vous seriez pas préférer une
liste d'union plutôt coup finalement
abondance de liste et l'ère où elle est
compatible de nuit pourvu que tout le
monde passe
écoutez pour vous poser une question
spécifique eure-et-loir département
voisin du mien le rapporteur général du
budget albéric de montgolfier avec
chantal de seine conduit la liste qui à
l'investiture de la majorité sénatoriale
il ya une autre liste c'était déjà le
cas la fois précédente
donc ça traduit des diversités de
sensibilité les délégués sénatoriaux
choisiront en fonction de ses
sensibilités
nous l'avons dans d'autres départements
l'a parfois sur des familles politiques
un peu différente
je pense en haute savoie par exemple
mais je pense que
c'est les délégués sénatoriaux genre
fait confiance qui feront le choix et
autres questions sébastien sur la
présidence du sénat oui alors vous
orienter une candidature pour un
quatrième mandat vous serez sûrement
réduit au plateau comment vous envisagez
cette future séquence qui sera sans
doute plus politique parce qu'elle se
profile vers la présidentielle dans un
rôle d'opposant par exemple écouter
d'abord merci pour vos prévisions vu de
chartres qui lui ordonne une dimension
spirituelle forte
nous verrons je serai candidat montrent
les unes je serai candidat
j'espère que mes collègues me
manifesteront leur confiance quel est
mon objectif pour les trois ans qui
viennent
bien sûr si laitiers dans une élection
sénatoriale ya six ans la question prône
aurait posé en premier est ce que le
sénat survivra encore trois ans à quoi
sert le sénat c'est des questions qu'on
se pose beaucoup moins jeu je m'en rends
compte parce que collectivement les
sénateurs aussi bien de la majorité que
des groupes d'opposition est minoritaire
tous se sont vraiment impliqués dans
leur rôle
sébastien couratin non pas de danty
pouvoir mais de contre-pouvoir et vous
faire simplement donner un chiffre
76% des textes législatifs au cours de
cette dernière année ont été votés
conjointement par la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
mais plus 50% des amendements apportés
par le sénat on était dans le texte
c'est donc un enrichissement dans la
fabrique de la loi anti pouvoir mais
contre-pouvoir c'est ce que vous aurez
j'ai fait un excellent livre jadis
qu'ils s'appellent contre pouvoir avec
marion mort qui va nous marions moore
est toujours disponible et et j'exprime
ainsi que je crois que depuis la réforme
du quinquennat ou l'assemblée nationale
et la réplique sismique de l'élection
présidentielle il faut dans une
démocratie une assemblée qui n'est pas
le même calendrier qui n'est pas la même
composition du corps électoral et qui
est des pouvoirs parfois asymétriques
dans les lois ordinaires c'est les
députés qui l'emportent sur nous et
pourtant nous avons pour voter les
trois-quarts de textes anciens les
dernières questions pas dire justement
vous avez contribué à cet équilibre
pouvoirs exécutif législatif durant vos
mandats à droite vous êtes quand même
celui qui a fait le plus d'efforts pour
assembler si au fond parmi les candidats
qui ont incité ocon parvenait à se
dégager
est-ce que vous même vous pourriez être
intéressé par l'alecso présidence je
suis candidat à la présidence du sénat
et c'est la dernière
c'est le dernier mandat écouter cet
autre chose chaque chose en son temps on
and on jamais son entrée en regardant la
porte de sortie
c'est un principe assez classique y
compris dans la compétition deux chevaux
qui a été mon métier avant de devenir
s'adapter et merci beaucoup merci
monsieur le président d'avoir été notre
invité est d'avoir répondu aux questions
des journalistes de la presse
quotidienne régionale que je remercie
d'avoir été avec nous baptiste biz il
mary robinson sébastien cours atteints
et eric berger merci merci à tous et
échanger de ce petit tour de france qui
est important et ce qui me donne je
serai dans l'aisne et dans le territoire
de belfort
d'ici la fin de la semaine avant d'aller
dans le loir et cher oui voilà vous
poursuivez vous aussi votre tour de
france on va continuer à parler de votre
interview gérard larcher avec je le
disais marion mourgue qui va nous
rejoindre et benjamin morel mais d'abord
on va ré écouter vos propos sur la
question de la sécurité
c'est vrai qu'il ya une banalisation de
la violence mais nos concitoyens n'en
peuvent plus de la violence
votre confrère le mans de fitte et
bressuire qui ne passe pas allez dire
pour un secteur violent les images de
grenoble les images de toulouse
ce qu'on a vu sur les champs-elysées
mais aussi tout simplement ce qui m'a
été racontée à nîmes vendredi dernier
qui fait que le maire de nîmes a demandé
rendez vous au ministre de l'intérieur
c'est un territoire dans lequel il ya eu
un effort très le continuum de sécurité
engagés avec l'état mais qui est dans
une situation très difficile mais
montant vers alès la commune de fontanès
des élus agressé une insécurité dont il
s'agit aujourd'hui apporter une réponse
à ceux qui ont dit et souvenez vous il
ya dix jours à la droite s'empare de ce
dossier le gouvernement s'en rend
tellement content qu'il y consacre
aujourd'hui un séminaire et qu'elle y
consacre me semble-t-il
moi je pense qu'il faut réfléchir au
continuum de sécurité on nous promet
depuis deux ans un livre blanc sur la
sécurité
je n'ai rappelait d'ailleurs premier
ministre en l'état le projet te quand
même reprend des mots qui ne
m'appartiennent pas qui était à
l'exécutif à un monument de technocratie
il faut donc qu'on fasse concret je
pense qu'il faut qu'on le sorte ce livre
blanc est que ce livre blanc dans le
continuum il doit partir du maire
première acteurs de la sécurité et qu'il
aille jusqu'à la réponse pénale et à
l'exécution de la peine
il ne suffit pas de mobiliser policiers
gendarmes policiers municipaux dans ce
couple d'ailleurs préfet maire il faut
aussi derrière et on l'a longtemps nié
que la réponse judiciaire soit à la
hauteur donc plus sévères qu'aujourd'hui
pas simplement plus sévère il faut aussi
plus de magistrats en plus impliqué dans
les rouges
j'ai changé avec le procureur général
et ils me disaient les piles de dossiers
qui aujourd'hui entre la grève des
avocats
le confinement l'augmentation d'un été
qui a été très difficile sur les côtes
très difficile en matière de sécurité
la difficulté qui a porté répose il me
disait la priorité c'est d'avoir des
greffiers la priorité c'est d'avoir des
magistrats mais encore plus des
greffiers voyez que quand on va sur le
territoire on prend la température quand
un procureur général vous dis cela vous
ne pouvez pas de preuves prendre en
compte et je pense que ce sera une des
demandes pour ce continuum du cycle et
nous allons donc revenir sur cette
interview qu'il nous a accordée à gérard
larcher avec marion mourgue bonjour
marion bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes journaliste au
figaro et vous êtes l'auteur gérard
larcher le rappeler de contre-pouvoir
livre d'entretiens avec le président du
sénat benjamin morel bonjour je vous
remercie d'être avec nous vous êtes
politologue
on va revenir sur cette interview
d'abord avant de revenir sur le fond
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
globalement de l'interview du président
du sénat vous citiez le titre
contre-pouvoir je trouve que par rapport
à il ya un an et justement pour avoir
beaucoup suivi gérard larcher il est un
peu moins critique à l'égard du
gouvernement
il utilise l'expression toujours de
contre-pouvoir mais c'est plus mesurés
parce que justement il ya l'arrivée de
jean castex et il le rappelait lui-même
jean castex a beaucoup parlé des
territoires donc on sent le président du
sénat aujourd'hui qui est plus dans la
tente qui demandent des résultats qui
dit place aux travaux pratiques mais qui
à la limite attend de voir
et donc on sent qu'il ya cette position
ça n'empêche pas quelques critiques sur
la politique et au niveau national
notamment sur la sécurité mais je dirais
qu'il ya plus un regard
je ne sais pas si c'est bienveillant
mais attentif il a changé d'optique
marché a changé
en tout cas en effet on note un
changement de ton qui est un changement
de ton important alors avec un ton
beaucoup plus accommodant xavier du
gouvernement il ya probablement un effet
castex il ya également un effet crise ça
iter crise économique on est sur des
points essentiels sur lequel trop cliver
et bien n'est pas forcément payant
ensuite il ya également un effet
sénatoriales là aujourd'hui pour des
maires pour des élus qui sont dans une
qui sont beaucoup moins polarisé
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
il est important d'avoir un discours
modéré il est important d'avoir un
discours d'ouverture notamment en vue
des prochains projets de lois 3d et
cetera donc là on a un président du
sénat qui aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus
dans l'expectative on va reparler de ces
questions de territoire de
décentralisation puisque gérard larcher
en a longuement parlé mais d'abord la
question de la sécurité on réécoute est
ce qu a dit le président du sénat et
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être le sujet
sur lequel il est le plus critique
vis-à-vis du gouvernement marion oui et
c'est là où il ya deux différences
d'approché visiblement entre emmanuel
macron qui serait peut-être plus issus
de la gauche de son ancienne famille
politique et gérard larcher qui
revendique pour le coup d'être vraiment
de droite et on sent que la question
régaliennes et un des angles d'attaqué
de la droite à l'égard des manuels
macron donc pour gérard larcher le
compte n'y est pas ils parlent
d'insécurité il parle aussi de la
question de l'égalité hommes et femmes
qui c'est vrai apparaît de plus en plus
dans le débat et qui pour lui est aussi
une préoccupation donc là en effet il ya
une critique il yal'idée il faut passer
aux actes et il faut qu'il y ait
notamment de l'application des peines
est à dire que la justice puisse
vraiment sanctionnés et que
l'application de la peine après un délit
n'arrive pas deux à trois ans après et
c'est peut-être l'homme de droite qui
parlait sur ce thème de la sécurité plus
que le président du sénat benjamin morel
c'est sans doute l'homme de droite ça
veut pas dire que au sénat ce n'est pas
une préoccupation est évidemment
essentiel mais très clairement par
rapport à ce qui était dit quand gérard
larcher dit tout à l'heure il ya un
espace politique pour la droite c'est
vrai aujourd'hui vous avez une partie de
l'électorat qui se reconnaît encore dans
une identité politique est une entité de
droite et qui d'une certaine façon
aujourd'hui
eh bien on l'a vu aux européennes peut
voter utile lrm pour une partie cet
électorat peut voter utile également et
rennes à peu près dans les mêmes
proportions que les rues m
mais se reconnaît des moments où ils
croient en une chance de victoire sur
ses propres couleurs dans cette identité
de droite traditionnelle disons le la
question c'est comment arriver à faire
exister cette espace politique
avec quels hommes évidemment mais
également sur quelles thématiques les
thématiques sont aujourd'hui
difficile à trouver que les hommes
plutôt il n'y a pas cette thématique est
trop d'hommes est l'une des thématiques
qui marque tout de même cet espace
électoral qui le distingue notamment par
rapport à l'air m
c'est la sécurité d'où l'importance
aujourd'hui pour la droite de bien
insister dessus
et justement vous qui suivez
particulièrement la droite un mario est
ce que ça peut être un piège pour les
républicains le fait que le gouvernement
parle autant de sécurité en cette
rentrée
oui parce que justement ça fait exister
cette musique que le gouvernement ferait
une politique de droite
ce que contestent les républicains mais
c'est vrai qu'on voit emmanuel macron et
l'ensemble du gouvernement arrivé sur
ces questions avec des déplacements avec
des ja lire des colloques fin des
comités pour parler justement de
séparatisme comme aujourd'hui donc oui
il faut que les républicains arrive à se
faire entendre sur ces questions là qui
sont vraiment dans l'adn de la droite
mais ça pose la question de
l'incarnation c'est à dire que qui parle
pour les républicains
quelle est la voie qui fait qu'on se dit
tiens les républicains ont dit ça
puisque aujourd'hui vous avez plutôt une
multiplication des voix alors il parle
de talent certes mais les français
attendent aussi une incarnation
on va revenir sur cette question
d'incarnation et mais sur ces questions
de sécurité gérard larcher a aussi parlé
des des agressions mer des agressions
d'élus locaux ça on sait c'est un sujet
que le sénat suis particulièrement
depuis plusieurs mois oui il le
rappelait ce n'est pas nouveau c'est le
précédent qui avait déclenché la
polémique et fait que tout le monde s'en
étaient saisi de cette question c'était
à l'été dernier donc il y a un an c'est
vrai que c'est monté en puissance que
les agressions de mer se multiplient et
que le sénat avait travaillé dessus mais
que le gouvernement semble plus
aujourd'hui il prendre la mesure de la
situation et a pris des dispositions
pour qu'il y ait des vraies sanctions
qu'ils soient appliqués mais c'est une
préoccupation des élus parce que ça
entraîne aussi des élus à ne plus
vouloir continuer parce que c'est quand
même d'une violence sans et un sentiment
général qui ya finalement un manque de
respect qui s'accentue envers les élus
envers les représentants
oui on en d'autorité très clairement
aujourd'hui qui déborde l'ensemble de la
société mais qui sur les élus
et notamment sur le rôle du maire
aujourd'hui est extrêmement préoccupant
et là on a un sénat qui est dans son
rôle pour le coup il est à la fois le
représentant des collectivités
territoriales il est également leurs
relais dans le champ politique central
être capable pour le sénat de faire des
enquêtes et ensuite de porter le
résultat de ces enquêtes au niveau
national pour amender la loi comme
ç'avait été un peu fait dans le cadre
d'engagements et proximité là on est
dans le coeur du métier sénatoriales
elle est l'autre sujet d'inquiétude déjà
arraché c'est cette crise économique un
et notamment ses conséquences en termes
d'emploi avant de vous entendre on va
écouter ce que disait le président du
sénat sur 7,4 sociales annoncées je
pense que nous avons le risque d'une
densité de sinistres industriels dans un
certain nombre de secteurs je ne dis pas
que de caste sinistres industriels
le secteur de l'automobile même si psa
se porte mieux que renault
je ne peux pas vous dire moi l'élu des
yvelines
je ne suis pas inquiet par le sinistre
renault dans la vallée de la seine avec
des conséquences sociales assez
terrifiante dans un territoire qui
souffre depuis des années est donc nous
pouvons avoir une période extrêmement
difficile
voilà pourquoi dans cette période il
suffit pas de se montrer du doigt
mutuellement faut essayer d'aider porter
notre pays c est ça aussi c'est un sujet
qui concerne le sénat qui concerne les
territoires et que gérard h et sud
presse oui et quelles que soient les
territoires c'est vrai qu'il le disait
dans sa permanence le nombre de gens qui
viennent le solliciter pour un emploi et
c'est assez vrai dans chaque territoire
c'est-à-dire que il parle de sinistres
industriels certains sont annoncés mais
il ya une préoccupation de l'ensemble
des français quel que soit sont sa
profession de perdre son emploi donc ça
c'est une vraie préoccupation et c'est
vrai que ça rejoint ce que benjamin aura
le disais tout à l'heure que dans ce
contexte en effet il est moins dans
l'idée de contre-pouvoir que
d'accompagner pour essayer que justement
permettre qu'une politique soit utile
pour tous benjamin oui quand vous
prendrez aujourd'hui les enquêtes où il
est que la préoccupation économique et
social est extrêmement importante serait
étonné du contraire mais vous avez à la
fois un contexte et vous avez un
ressenti pour la parole politique arrivé
justement à mettre en scène ce concret
et montrer que face à ce concret qui est
un peu désespérant
il peut y avoir des solutions saas est
un élément assez importants du discours
politique et du langage politique
vous avez un gérard larcher qui connaît
ce secteur là qui connaît au regard de
ses anciennes responsabilités
gouvernementales
là où on voit très clairement qu'on a en
ainsi un ministre qui connaît son sujet
et qui essaye justement est bien d'avoir
un langage qui est audible mais
j'ajouterai juste un mot c'est que pour
le président du sénat
les résultats être très concret et
pouvoir dire aux français voilà on a
fait ça ça a servi à quelque chose sur
lui participe de l'importance de
rétablir la confiance entre élus et
citoyens c'est à dire qu'il se dit si on
n'a pas de résultats
c'est fini et c'est aussi la porte
ouverte aux extrêmes à la prochaine
présidentielle et gérard larcher qui ne
critique pas le plan de relance alors
qui ne précise pas clairement critiqué
le calendrier
il critique la cadré mais il ne critique
pas le fond il ne critique pas ce plan
de 100 milliards annoncés non parce que
en effet il y a besoin d'aidé il est
plus sur le calendrier et puis sur
l'utilisation notamment par exemple de
la tva donc c'est comment le plan de
relance ensuite se se dispatchent un peu
donc voila mais c'est des critiques à la
marge
en effet même s'il dit aujourd'hui le
plan de relance tel qu'il est conçu fait
que son application pour les français et
les entreprises c'est finalement fin de
l'année début de l'année prochaine
donc ils appellent à des décrets qui
soit déjà voté parce que ça arrive trop
tard selon li et marion le disait il ils
s'intéressent à l'impact de ce plan de
relance sur les collectivités notamment
sur l'autonomie financière il a parlé
des communes il a parlé des départements
oui là la question et langues
elle est lancinante elle ne date pas en
fait du plan de relance 1 c'est à dire
que ce cas décrit gérard larcher en
terme de passage d'un impôt d'une
collectivité un autre et d'un
département qui hériterait d'une partie
de la tva pour compenser le l'impôt
passer au bloc communal c'est quelque
chose qu'on voyait déjà poindre en fin
d'année dernière la question sans effet
comment est-ce qu'on maintient le
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
territoriales aujourd'hui elle est
réduite à peau de chagrin
ça pose des questions et ça pose des
enjeux démocratiques
gérard larcher
explique que pour l'instant c'est pas
forcément ce qui est le plus important
c'est d'ailleurs intéressant que non pas
qu'ils se désolidarisent mais qui en
tout cas elle ne se solidarise pas de la
mf sur ces sujets là il reporte cette
idée d'autonomie financière à la loi 3d
a priori c'est pas tout à fait encore
dans les papiers concernant cette toi
donc il va falloir revoir là si vraiment
il ya des évolutions pas je nuancerais
un tout petit peu parce que pour l'avoir
suivi
encore lundi en reportage c'est quand
même une de ses préoccupations la
question des régulations financières sur
la collectivité et je sais pas s'ils se
désolidarise des associations d'élus il
prévient bien les élus en disant je suis
pas forcément en mesure de vous dire
comment financera dans quelques années
donc c'est vraiment une préoccupation je
dirais immédiate en est justement
puisque vous parlez des territoires et
de décentralisation manoela il a
beaucoup parlé aussi un de ces questions
durant cette interview ils ont le
soutien que le sénat l'avait présenté 50
propositions pour une nouvelle
décentralisation en juillet et le
président du sénat l'a dit elles seront
examinées sous forme de proposition de
loi à partir du mois d'octobre
oui alors c'est peut-être là qui se
montrera plus critiques à l'endroit du
gouvernement si justement il n'y a pas
une application concrète de ces mesures
de décentralisation et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui avec la crise du coc vide
tous les élus demandent à ce qu'il y ait
plus de décentralisation que les
réponses soient locales qu'elles soient
liées à des bassins de vie
donc c'est on va voir à partir d'octobre
s'il ya six gouvernement prend la mesure
et c'est vrai que là on verra peut-être
le sénat ensuite parler plus fort entre
guillemets quoi et c'est à partir de ce
moment là comme dit marion que le sénat
sera sera plus à l'offensive et que
gérard larcher sera plus à l'offensive
sur ces questions de décentralisation
c'est difficile de le dire quand on
regarde un petit peu les projets de
l'eau aujourd'hui qui sont en gestation
vous avez le projet de loi organique sur
la différenciation donc là qui devrait
être examiné au sénat mais on est dans
le cas d'une morgan it les enjeux
peuvent être importants mais il reste
relativement limité ensuite vous avez le
projet de loi 3d qui est prévue à
l'automne est là il ya de vrais vrai
enjeu parce qu'on sait que la
différenciation il sera présente la
déconcentration elle passera plutôt par
voie réglementaire
le volet décentralisation lui il
apparaît beaucoup plus problématique
très clairement on est plutôt dans le
cadre à priori d'une réforme a minima
sur le volet décentralisation veille
différenciation pose d'autres problèmes
sont des accords de l'uag gérard larcher
cette question là quand on prend
aujourd'hui les enquêtes en bretagne en
alsace on voit que le séparatisme et le
régionalisme est dopé par ses
perspectives la va falloir faire
attention
je renvoie au sondage csa notamment en
alsace qui est paru au mois de janvier
de cette année mais le volet
décentralisation lui pose un réel
problème parce que sur l'hôpital
il ya eu des avancées de jean castex a
priori et ce sont des avancées minimes
et extrêmement floues la plupart des
revendications des associations d'élus
sur ces questions là aujourd'hui n'ont
pas été comblées et donc là il va y
avoir un vrai bras de fer entre le
gouvernement qui voudrait en être le
moins possible et le sénat qui
voudraient aller le plus loin possible
il n'est pas dit que au vu du contexte
politique à ce moment là on sera en
pleine élection régionale et
départementale ce soit tout à fait à
l'avantagé du gouvernement et marion 1
est ce que les choses ont changé depuis
l'arrivée de jean castex aussi bien au
niveau des associations d'élus de
territoire unique que gérard larcher
suit de très près ce que jean castex il
a changé les choses
disons qu'il a mis une liaison plus
direct parce que c'est un maire qui
revendique le mode territoire alors
edouard philippe l'était aussi
mais c'était le début du quinquennat la
majorité présidentielle arrivée de
manière plus conquérante aujourd'hui il
ya une volonté de dialogue
il ya aussi la reconnaissance par le
gouvernement de l'importance des
associations d'élus elles se sont fait
entendre depuis trois ans elles ont même
réussi à être unie et à créer un
partenariat avec son appel territoire
unique donc les communes et départements
les régions par l'ensemble ce qui pèse
dans le débat politique donc c'est aussi
ça qui a changé c'est le rapport de
force
en ce moment on dirait qu'il est
presqu'à égalité on va voir ensuite
comment ça évolue dans les prochains
mois gérard larcher qui a bien sûr parlé
de la droite de son parti qui se cherche
un candidat avant de vous entendre on va
ré coûté le président du sénat hier
comité stratégique
il a été décidé que la procédure
concrètes seraient mises en oeuvre après
ce qui doit être notre priorité les
élections départementales et les
élections régionales mais que d'ici là
un groupe de travail pouvait préparer
des partages et comme j'ai dit je
prendrai mes responsabilités je les
prendrai j'ai dit à port marly que je ne
laisserai pas faire n'importe quoi
donc je vais il redit mais c'est quoi
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi ce serait
d'avoir deux candidats au premier tour
c'est la certitude de ne pas être au
second tour ce serait une faute contre
la démocratie
gérard larcher qui reste sur sa ligne
sur ce sujet 1
marion oui mais j'ai envie dire il ya
encore du travail à droite hier au
comité stratégique
les participants à la limite se sont mis
d'accord sur la question de la primaire
alors on peut dire que ça avance un peu
parce qu'avant cette question était
tabou mais le chemin est encore long
le processus de désignation est encore
long aujourd'hui la majorité est plutôt
d'accord pour que ce processus
interviennent après les régionales même
si certains versent de bruno retailleau
aurait aimé que au moins on mette en
place ce processus ça veut pas dire
qu'on décide mais qu'on mette en place
vous voyez le nombre d'étapes qui a
avant sachant qu' il se dit inquiet si
jamais il ya deux candidats de la droite
façon chirac balladur et c'est une vraie
question sauf qu'aujourd'hui xavier
bertrand a déjà annoncé qu'il ne se
soumettrait pas à une primaire à ce
système de départage
donc on voit le nombre d'embûches qu'il
ya sur le chemin de la droite pour avoir
un candidat et gérard larcher qui se dit
prêt à jouer le rôle de sage qui peut
ramener l'unité ou garantir l'unité de
sa famille oui il a déjà eu ce rôle de
sage à plusieurs reprises
donc c'est sûr qu'il y aura plusieurs
personnalités c'est assez logique qu'il
en fasse partie
mais on sent que c'est un peu poussif
comme processus de désignation c'est à
dire que la primaire en 2016
il y avait une sorte de dynamique alors
certes il y avait eu des réunions pour
organiser tout ça mais il ya une sorte
de dynamique dès le départ là on se dit
que si déjà il faut un comité de sages
pour arriver à s'entendre sur le
processus c'est mal parti
oui il faut bien comprendre que
on a un espace politique et structuré
plus tôt par une tradition bonapartiste
il attend un chef et les lecteurs pour
croire en une chance de victoire
c'est pas seulement la cinquième
république c'est également la culture
politique de cet espace a besoin d'un
chef
un chef qui émerge aujourd'hui serait
idéal parce qu'il pourrait capitaliser
sur une victoire de la droite
départementale et régionale qui apparaît
tout de même assez probable est donc
faire croire à ses électeurs que la
victoire est possible et donc
performative m'en faire advenir une
victoire là aujourd'hui
ce processus est extrêmement compliqué
parce qu'en fait vous n'avez plus
d'instances de régulation qui permet de
légitimer une candidature lr avait la
possibilité que ce soit par les
primaires ou que ce soit par un mode de
désignation interne lors des dernières
élections d'annoncer un candidat et ce
candidat a été vue légitime par
l'ensemble de l'électorat de droite
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas arrivé
à reconstruire de la légitimité pour re
légitimer ensuite un candidat c'est tout
l'enjeu
je pense qu'actuellement le calendrier
apparaît un peu tardif oui et un
calendrier d'autant plus tardif que
certains élus à l'image de christian
estrosi ont déjà fait savoir que
emmanuel macron pourrait être le
potentiel candidat de la droite enfin
d'une partie de la droite et donc sa
bouille le message quand gérard larcher
dit les français lui en parle pas oui il
n'ya pas cette question de la
présidentielle mais il ya quand même
cette demande qu'il ya une voie pour
parler pour représenter la droite est
donc aujourd'hui le fait qu'il ne
tranche pas que les élus les
républicains ne tranche pas sa bouille
le messager est mort rapidement marion
sur françois baroin françois baroin dont
gérard larcher dit qu'il ne connaît pas
encore sa décision
oui enfin il explique aussi en privé que
françois baroin ne lui a pas dit donc je
modère elle mais vous qui croyez savoir
qu'il a que françois baroin a renoncé à
il ne serait pas candidat à la
présidentielle
on va faire un an va les voir fanny
conquis qu'il va nous faire un point sur
les unes de vos quotidiens régionaux
aujourd'hui tous ont commencé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous on commence cette revue
de presse ce matin avec la une du maine
libre et la campagne des sénatoriales le
scrutin a lieu dans trois semaines le
dimanche 27 septembre
et dans le contexte de crise sanitaire
que l'on connaît et bien évidemment la
campagne est forcément particulière une
campagne électorale en catimini pour les
candidats au sénat
c'est à lire ce matin dans le maine
libre on poursuit avec l'yonne
républicaine
autre élection qui s'était déroulé dans
un contexte particulier ce sont
évidemment les municipales du mois de
juin et le journal titre ce matin mer
depuis deux mois
qu'ont ils fait cet été fut studieux
pour les élus la rédaction était
interrogé certains d'entre eux les
maires de sang soo de monéteau par
exemple témoignage à lire ce matin dans
le journal à la une des dernières
nouvelles d'alsace et la déception pour
la france et pour la ville de strasbourg
en effet la semaine prochaine le
parlement européen siègera à bruxelles
et non pas à strasbourg après six mois
d'absence
une décision que regrette de nombreux
élus les avec le département du bas rhin
qui est classé en zone rouge
et bien le risque sanitaire est jugée
encore trop élevé on passe maintenant à
la une de la provence on parle de
marseille et plus particulièrement du
vieux-port tapage nocturne décrit la
musique les rodéos urbains
une situation qui est devenue
insupportable pour les riverains
certains envisagent de déménager et ils
ont même lancé une pétition et je vous
propose de regarder aussi dans la
provence c'est à lire ce matin l'édito
qui évoque le cas de jean castex vous le
savez il est devenu qu'à contacter après
avoir côtoyé le directeur du tour de
france lui même testé positif au co vide
le premier ministre a donc été testée il
a eu les résultats rapidement et ce
n'est pas le cas de monsieur tout le
monde nous rappelle philippe schmitt qui
signe cet édito ce matin peut-être
faudrait-il réfléchir à une autre
méthode pour mieux cibler pour accélérer
les tests et leurs résultats
ce sera peut-être l'objet du conseil de
défense qui est prévue ce vendredi je
vous propose de terminer cette revue de
presse avec nice matin qui parle des
facs qui elles aussi doivent faire face
à cette épidémie de covile 19
en cette rentrée les étudiants sont
inquiets certaines salles sont bondées
les universités réagissent les amphis
sont divisés par deux on rétablit les
cours à distance reste à savoir si tout
cela sera efficace face à l'épidémie
et merci beaucoup fanni pour cette revue
de presse merci marion mourgue on peut
voir la une du figaro
aujourd'hui macron durci le ton face au
séparatisme islamistes c'est à lire ce
matin dans le figaro et puis on va
revoir votre livre un contre-pouvoir
livre avec gérard larcher merci bonjour
maman d'avoir été avec nous et puis je
remercie les journalistes de la presse
quotidienne régionale qui était à mes
côtés pour cette interview julien
lécuyer de la voix du nord pascal
jalabert du groupe ebra baptiste bise de
la nouvelle république qui je marie
robin de ouest france eric berger de la
dépêche du midi et sébastien cours
atteints de l'écho républicain je vous
donne rendez vous demain à 7h30 pour un
nouveau numéro d'on jour chez vous très
bonne journée
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous ont présenté le
club des territoires
la mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous a présenté le club
des territoires angie acteurs engagés
dans la transition zéro carbone des
régions vous a présenté le club des
territoires
[Musique]